hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the average daily number of new
coronavirus cases in the u.s
dropping below 100 000 for the first
time since october
according to data from johns hopkins
university fox news contributor and
board certified medical doctor jeanette
neshawat
discusses the vaccine rollout concerns
about other virus strains
and why she's optimistic about the
nation's fight against
covid19 while states begin to ease
restrictions on restaurants and other
businesses
many school districts continue to
struggle with how to return to in-person
learning
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on the biden administration's
political headache
over how and when to get more schools
open amid the pandemic
and the nursing home scandal plaguing
new york governor andrew cuomo
plus commentary from fox nation host tom
chalu
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com i'm martha
mccallum i'm bill hemmer
i'm shannon breem and this is the fox
news rundown
friday february 19th 2021
i'm dave anthony it's a positive trend
lately
fewer americans testing positive for
kovit
hopefully it stays like that because we
still have those variants that are out
there the uk variant and the
south african variant that could be a
problem during spring break
i'm lisa brady the new president and his
team hit some turbulence
over cobit messaging people are going to
judge this
on on the reality of their lives not
whether there was some
uh contradiction between what the
president and his press secretary said
plus the former president speaks and
cancel culture with fox news sunday host
chris wallace
and i'm tom chalu i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
we've seen this trend before when the
coronavirus
seemed to be on the decline late summer
and then as we were warned
came a big spike in the fall and early
winter
that we hope peaked last month kova 19
cases have now been declining for five
weeks cdc director dr rochelle walinski
nearly every day the past two weeks
there have been fewer than a hundred
thousand new cases in the u.s
and if you combine this past sunday
monday tuesday and wednesday
still doesn't add up to the one day
record on the johns hopkins tracker
of 300 000 new infections reported back
on january 2nd
but dr wolenski also urges us not to get
complacent
consistently and correctly wearing a
mask is one of the
most effective tools we have to spread
stop the spread of coca-19
and by july we've been told there should
be enough coronavirus vaccine doses for
every american
yeah the numbers thank goodness have
gone down dr jeanette neshwatt is a
board certified medical doctor
and fox news contributor and i think
it's a combination
of factors we've passed the major
holidays thanksgiving
christmas and new year's were definitely
you know
time of the year where we saw a lot of
travel we saw a lot of social gathering
and we saw a lot of spread of the virus
but with that behind us and also with
mitigation efforts of wearing your mask
and maybe
maybe even the vaccine may have had a
small
a small role in this we're seeing the
numbers
finally go down and hopefully it stays
like that because
we still have those variants that are
out there the uk variant and the
south african variant that could be a
problem in during spring break
you said maybe the vaccine we're doing
according to the white house a rate of
about 1.7
million vaccinations a day maybe less
with the winter storm
affecting things in the across the
country in the last week or so
but if you do the math that's about 12
million people in a week
and the total number of confirmed covet
cases in the us is under 28 million so
that's a lot of people being vaccinated
yeah
yeah it is it's it's a it's a good
number we're picking up momentum more
and more
are being vaccinated every week and
we've been doing that with moderna we've
been doing that with john uh with uh
pfizer and and soon hopefully we'll have
johnson and johnson to add to the mix
and also
the astrazeneca vaccine and
uh even novavax is coming out with a
vaccine so
it's estimated by the end of july that
everyone
that will have availability for everyone
uh to be vaccinated we should have
approximately
600 million doses um for all of
americans to be vaccinated so
we're on we're on the way there people
are getting impatient though people
getting impatient
because they're trying even those who
are eligible having a hard time signing
up
so what i would say is keep trying
i know it's easier said than done but be
patient it's not like you have
nothing it's not like you're defenseless
without the vaccine you can still
protect yourself by
masking and practice physical distancing
and avoiding crowds and congregations
um and uh you know be careful if in
social gathering events that's where
we're seeing a lot of the spread of the
virus so
we still have the tools we still have
the capability to protect yourself
until it's your turn to get your vaccine
but yeah right now the
the demand outweighs the supply but um
it's just a matter of time
um until everyone will will get it don't
let your guard down too soon
you reference these variants the uk
strain
brazil south africa what is the biggest
concern you have about them
well my biggest concern for example with
the uk strain
it's found to be about 30 percent more
lethal
the uk string the south african strain
are significantly more contagious
um just in the manner of the spike
protein how it can attach to the cells
and infect this easier
so if it can affect this easier it can
spread easier and that could result in
another spike in your surge
in in the next you know four to eight
weeks during during spring break so
those are my concerns fortunately the
vaccines that we have the data shows
that
the vaccines will still be effective
against those variants
although slightly diminished
effectiveness
but we need to vaccinate as rapidly as
possible before
the mutations in the these variants
get to the point where the vaccine is
not effective
we're nowhere near that but i don't want
that to happen
have you had any patients or seen a lot
of patients who've been dealing with a
lot of side effects of the vaccines
people talk about getting
sick a little bit after the first water
especially after the second one
have you have you had a lot of that very
very mild
very very mild maybe a headache maybe
some body aches
some chills or fever for like a day and
then they're back to normal
i had a headache and maybe some body
aches for half a day
and it didn't stop me from doing
anything i needed to do took two tylenol
and was fine
the most significant side effect that
i've ever had a patient have
was actually very a very mild rash
um but no i have not had many patients
with many
uh side effects most of them did
perfectly fine
and continue to do so and
the risk of any severe side effects or
severe allergic reactions
is very very low have you
personally or do you know of people who
have tested positive
after getting the vaccine have you had
that yet i've had a couple of patients
that tested positive but they only had
their first dose they were not
fully vaccinated so i have had one one
patient
she's actually 90 years old and she got
her first dose of pfizer
and then uh i think about two weeks
three weeks later she did test positive
for covet
but her symptoms were so mild she said
oh i just thought i had a little cold
but she hadn't yet had her her second
um dose and she was she did perfectly
fine she recovered
perfectly well she had no complications
she did not have to be hospitalized
um she just had a little bit of a runny
nose but that's the only question that i
can
um can that i can think of of all the
hundreds of coveted patients that i've
been taking care of
over the past few months since the
vaccine has been available
this downward covered trend has put more
focus
on reopening classrooms still closed
we want the children to be in school
many parents in areas where kids are
still learning at home have been
demanding that
house speaker nancy pelosi says many
districts
still need more money to make that
happen there's 130 billion dollars in
the proposed new coveted relief package
you need more space therefore you need
more teachers
therefore you need more buses for kids
to be spaced
to come to school you need better
ventilation
and president biden says the goal is to
get most students
kindergarten through eighth grade back
in classrooms again
dr neshwatt says they need to be we're
hurting our children
by not getting them in the classroom
psychologically mentally physically
emotionally
the benefit of being in the classroom
far outweighs any risk of
of covid transfer the data tells us that
the transmission of covet in
in the classroom is much less of that in
the community
so i think if you have a low prevalence
of covet in the community
less than 10 positivity our schools need
to be open kids need to be in the
classroom
um they're not only losing um
having a loss of learning and education
but it's having a significant mental
toll
on children on families on parents you
know we're seeing
a rise in opioid abuse alcohol abuse
anxiety and depression
so i think you know just take a look for
example at florida their schools have
been open
on certain parts of the country schools
have been open they've been doing well
and we're not seeing
any significant differences in the
number of cases of where areas where
they're closed
and if you look at the latest data out
of this cdc the the study out of
wisconsin which
followed 17 different schools they found
that only three percent of the coveted
transmission in those within those
schools were
from the classroom were from um teachers
and students
so that was very low and very clear
evidence
that it's time to open up and get our
kids back in the classroom
and so you agree with the cdc the
teachers don't have to be vaccinated in
order to be in school i mean it's
obviously optimal for them but they
don't have to be
could it help yes it certainly could
help and and that's why
like for example here in new york
teachers are getting vaccinated so i
think
we need to continue to make them a top
priority but
um while we're waiting for everyone to
get their vaccine
which is of course a big problem the
supply let's not hold back opening the
schools
because again best one of the best ways
to protect yourself in school is
number one wear on your mask number two
making sure that we have good
ventilation and airflow opening windows
opening doors
maybe having hybrid schedules making
sure that the classes aren't
packed jammed you know full making sure
the desks are spread apart
so taking all these measures and also
trying to get your vaccine i think
together
will make it safe one thing that hardly
anyone
has talked about in the last several
months because of the coronavirus
is the flu and so the statistics for the
flu
are really something this season
there are somewhere i've looked at the
laboratory in the according to the cdc
around 1500 a little over 1500
cases of the flu one
pediatric death 165
flu related hospitalizations the entire
season
it's just phenomenal and i'm so happy to
see this but i'm not surprised
yes less than 200 hospitalizations
between october
1st 2020 and between between
october and february of this year less
than 200 hospitalizations
the year prior dave we had almost half a
million people who were hospitalized for
flu
um so and the death rate is just almost
gone down to nothing
and that's because the same mitigation
prevention
measures that we took for covid work
against
flu as well so if you're wearing your
mask if you're keeping your hands washed
and clean
avoid rubbing your eyes and your nose um
keeping physical distance and if you get
your flu vac vaccine
you're going to be protected we had
record number of of patients getting
their flu shots this past year so
i think all of the together really
helped make the flu season non-existent
and hopefully it continues like that
you know i i have not been out too much
and uh i haven't had a cold for a year
at least
and i didn't get the flu either and have
you seen a lot of people with a cold
even
i've had maybe just a couple of patients
that have had a cold that tested
negative for the flu they tested
negative for covid um but not many
others
and i think that all comes down to a
mass use and physical distancing
um i've had a few patients with strep
throat as well but
not very many the number of cases upper
respiratory infections
you know bronchitis pneumonias have gone
down
significantly this past year and i think
we can attribute to the
mitigation measures that we used um to
fight coping
you know it's different with flu and
cold you know obviously covert was so
airborne
and so contagious that way but with flu
and cold a lot of times you know when
we're
at work with people or school with
people
we're spreading it by not having our
hands washed but nowadays
people are washing their hands a ton do
you think that trend is going to
continue and that's going to be the way
it is
yes and i hope it does continue because
one of the
best ways to prevent the spread of
infection especially in hospitals
is simply by hand washing and that's why
we're seeing
um you know sanitizing stations and hand
washing stations pop up
in public areas in airports you know in
shopping
centers in this school so all these
these these measures can help reduce
transmission
of virus of bacterial infections and so
hopefully it will become
a norm for us as we move forward
dr janet neshwa fox news medical
contributor
thanks so much for joining us thank you
dave i appreciate it you have a
wonderful day
[Music]
this is tom chalu with your fox news
commentary coming up
a month into the biden administration
and a year into the pandemic
some rough sledding for the new
president especially on covid related
issues
in addition to the ongoing challenges
with the vaccine supply
virus variants and mask fatigue those
school reopening questions keep coming
back around
white house spokeswoman jinsaki says
president biden is focused
on returning to how schools were before
the pandemic we are also going to be
guided by science
we are going to be guided by our medical
experts we are going to be guided by the
guidelines of the cdc
but what is open actually mean saki
suggesting recently that as little as
one day a week of in-person instruction
could count
president biden later said that was a
mistake
well it's not good when the president
says
that there was some miscommunication of
how
open schools will be within 100 days
whether it'll be one day a week
or five days a week chris wallace is the
host of fox news sunday
having said that uh i you know i don't
know that it really matters because in
the end what really matters
is what the spokesperson says is whether
the schools are open
and and you know that's what uh the
biden administration is going to be
judged on is not words or message
although i will
agree with you that the message has been
somewhat garbled
uh but the key is going to be are more
people going to get vaccinated are they
going to get vaccinated faster are
schools
uh that are closed going to reopen or if
they're partially open one or two days a
week are they going to be open
five days a week you know in the end
people are going to
judge this on on the the reality of
their lives
not whether there was some uh
contradiction between what the president
and his press secretary said and then in
the meantime we had vice president
harris
seeming to contradict what dr fauschi
had said about not starting from scratch
on vaccines is the media pressing enough
on these
kinds of things or is the administration
getting a pass
no i i think it was interesting to watch
and and you know i think to a certain
degree
that the impeachment trial kept a lot of
the
i don't know about the country but
certainly the media focused on donald
trump
now donald trump although he's certainly
going to continue to be a factor in our
politics but
with impeachment over i think there's
more of a focus
on what uh the administration is or
isn't doing and and
savannah guthrie on on uh the today show
did a pretty tough interview of uh vice
president harris
uh on on questions of
uh the covered vaccine and also about
schools and it was interesting because
because savannah was pressing uh
the vice president on this issue that
that
in the latest cdc guidelines they say it
is not a precondition
that teachers have to be vaccinated to
go back to schools if you have a safe
environment ventilation and all of that
stuff
and she kept pressing uh harris to say
it and she wouldn't say it
and you know it seemed to me as just an
observer
that there was some politics at play
there harris kept talking the question
of whether
they had to be vaccinated and kept
saying we want
uh teachers to be you know a priority
group for vaccination
i think that has a lot to do with the
connection between the democratic party
and the teachers union but it was a it
was a tough interview and
you know good that's what we need to be
we need to be
as tough on liberals as as conservatives
on
democrats as republicans former
president trump kind of broke the ice
wednesday so to speak um talking to fox
news about
rush limbaugh do you think that we'll
see more of him now and
is president biden dreading that or do
democrats think it hurts republicans
if trump stays front and center oh i
think
democrats probably like uh donald trump
uh
being out out there um you know i think
they see him
you know it's the flip of what i just
said to you which is that to the degree
that that
trump leaves the scene or is is absent
on the scene there's more focus
on what dubai administration is or
isn't doing but donald trump is such a
focus of attention that when he's out
there and particularly
when he's out there creating a serious
split inside the republican party when
he takes off after
uh senate republican leader mitch
mcconnell and mcconnell takes off after
him
i think democrats just lick their chops
just as republicans lick their chops
when you've got
aoc and bernie sanders saying that joe
biden isn't going far enough you know
when you're
when your enemy is is uh destroying
itself
uh stay out of the way and let them
continue well and then we have the
scandal
involving the anti-trump lincoln project
which i know says
it wasn't just about anti-trump but are
they hurting chances for unity in the
republican party
or are they over as a group as as even
some supporters have been suggesting
i think they're pretty much over and and
look of course it was an anti-trump
group
you know it really was a trolling group
that put out these
uh effective uh videos you know you can
argue whether they were
were accurate or not but you know they
clearly
uh were trolling donald trump and and i
think probably getting under his skin
um and but you know as it turns out that
they they had some baggage of their own
you know their two stories i mean there
was the john weaver story uh one of the
founders of the group uh who
was sending all kinds of unsolicited
messages
to young men and and offering them
internships and
whether that was bait to get them to do
the things he wanted them to do
uh and then there's also a big
fundraising issue they raised something
like 90 million dollars i was shocked at
that
and there doesn't seem to have been a
full accounting of exactly where that
went and how it was spent
um i think the i think that the lincoln
group
has probably come and gone and uh
um you know that that again
and this is an example of it that that
the media
needs to be just as uh tough on
people who are in opposition to donald
trump as in people
who supported them at the same time
um it's all too easy to get cancelled
nowadays this cancel culture that people
are talking about
rush limbaugh's actually someone who
survived attacks over the years on his
advertisers for instance over some
controversial things he said
will it be harder for a personality like
him to survive
going forward because of the way the
climate has become
oh absolutely uh you know it it's one of
the things
that i i have to say i find shocking
that there seems to be zero tolerance
for people making
mistakes now i want to be very careful
as i discuss this subject because you
know you just
you you run the risk of of antagonizing
the thought police and i'm not scared
of them but i don't want to give them an
easy target and and
you know i just think this this constant
source of outrage that
you know people it's like you can't make
a mistake or you can't say
something and if you said it 10 years
ago
you're you're held to account and and
you know look
there are things that all of us have
said and done that that
you know if we had it to take back and
maybe in a different cult
cultural moment you know we have all
gotten i hope smarter and
more thoughtful about it but i don't
know when you see the the host of
of the bachelor suddenly there's talk
about canceling him
because as i understand it that he
basically was saying let's go easy on
this
woman for something she did several
years ago uh
and just the fact that he was saying
let's go easy now they want to cancel
him
it just it just makes you i don't know i
it
it it isn't good for democracy when uh
you know what we we've all learned and
there are different attitudes about race
and
uh women's rights and a variety of an
lgbtq and i understand all of that and
you know we need to accommodate the
times but the idea that
you know you're held to account uh and
not just held to account but
can literally be cancelled your career
can be over you can be thrown out
because of something you say or do or
said or did some time ago
i think it's very chilling and i and you
know
the whole point of the founders was a
vigorous first amendment let's be able
to discuss
things and thought is not action and
uh the idea that you can sort of be
banned from
business and society and uh you know
current life because of something you
say uh
i think it's very chilling and very
alarming there are some people who say
that someone who is not being held to
account at least not yet is
new york governor andrew cuomo over what
happened with kovid
in nursing homes although he says it's
really just an informational
issue that they didn't get information
out in a timely fashion
where do you think that is all heading
well i
i think he's being held to account now
now i don't mean by that that there's
been any
specific action taken but he's all over
the front pages of everything from the
new york post to the uh to the new york
times
which is quite a political spectrum uh
you know it it it sure seems
like there was an effort to
to hide the you know how
where people were dying first of all
there was the controversial issue that
he was
sending people with covid from hospitals
to nursing homes which seems like a
really wrong edit uh dumb
idea and then secondly and you know this
came out of the mouth of one of his top
aides
melissa de rosa that that you know they
were when they were asked by the federal
government
give us the straight numbers of where
people died
that you know they seem not to have been
uh
ready to hand that information over and
now there are stories that
you know some of the democrats because
not just republicans in new york
politics are going after him it's also
uh democrats and he's supposedly this
state senator mr kim he uh
supposedly said he was going to destroy
let me just say because we have this
with
t.j ducklow don't ever get on the phone
and say i'm going to destroy you because
boy if that ever comes out
the only person who gets destroyed is
the person who said it
so uh you know you got to be careful
what you say these days and i don't mean
that in the sense of
thought police i mean just don't don't
be saying things like we're gonna i'm
gonna destroy you
yeah right writing things down sometimes
not a good idea either
historically speaking um well chris
wallace host of fox news sunday we are
always thrilled to have you thank you so
much for your time
lisa thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts rate and review
the fox news rundown on apple podcasts
or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the brutal winter weather that left many
dealing with snow
ice power outages and no water or heat
has also brought out stories of kindness
one of those is in houston texas jim
mackinvale known as mattress mac
has turned his 100 000 square foot north
houston gallery furniture store
into a place that people who have no
heat or electricity could take refuge
so we open the showroom as a shelter for
people to come and get warm and
get a good night's sleep mattress mack
came on to the national scene in 2017
when he opened his store as a shelter
after flooding from hurricane harvey
left many unable to stay in their homes
this week hundreds have come to the
store to warm up
some of them even spending the night on
the beds and couches in the showroom
makingville told fox news he's also been
sleeping there we got lots of food here
we've got a
warm welcoming place a lot of people
obviously are traumatized
their homes are cold they have no
license no water he's also provided
meals to people during the coronavirus
pandemic
there's even playground furniture in the
children's area and macken bell says he
brought in
face painters for the kids we'll get
through this and
we're here to benefit the community
that's what we've always done and our
job is to
we have a responsibility for well-being
community we're trying to live it up to
that he says giving back to the
community is a way of life for him
you know my parents always taught me
that the essence of living is giving so
i've
tried to live that life and teach it to
my children and my
grandchild sydney was at her yesterday
she's learning that the essence of
living is giving so
we have an obligation to help the
community not just a responsibility but
an obligation
and when things like this happen our
team members rally around us and we all
get together and
see how we can help people that are in
need tonya jay powers
fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind i'm recording this
in my car
because that's where i used to spend a
lot of time
listening to rush limbaugh
just so you guys know i'm i'm pulling
over the side of the road to record this
you see as a young comedian on the road
i spent a lot of time in my car
with nothing but am radio and in many
parts of the country
the only choices were country music and
rush limbaugh
rush was available everywhere in fact
sometimes you'd be listening and the
signal would start to get a little snowy
so all you had to do was turn the dial
down a bit and
to the other side of the dial you'd find
another rush limbaugh station
and that would take you another 40 or 50
miles to get to the next
rush limbaugh station rush was a really
really smart guy but he talked like a
regular guy
he didn't make you feel like you were
getting talked down to but he had great
insight
into the way the world worked that was
his
great strength there's this idea out in
the world
you heard it repeated endlessly during
his career and you're hearing it
repeated now the idea he was turning
gullible americans into conservatives
but that's not the way it worked it was
the other way around
there is a lot of conservatives out
there in the country who just never had
someone articulating so clearly
the way that they felt rush did that and
he made them want to listen more that's
all
he would ask questions that made you go
yeah why is that
and you think why didn't i think of that
rush is gone now and we're gonna miss
him but he has left a very long
and deep legacy and not just from his
own show
but the countless other radio hosts and
now
podcasters that learn their craft from
him and model themselves after him
it is a vast world of conservative talk
out there
but there is never going to be another
rush
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes